as the sun went down in this small texan
town the community came together in
their hundreds
[Music]
a moment for prayer
to reflect on the unimaginable
beyond the hugs though how can anyone
explain to dads like stephen garcia why
his daughter ellie is gone
[Music]
there are private moments of grief all
over
so often places like this are said to be
tight-knit but you can feel it here
so many know someone now in so much pain
and yet even here even after something
like this the political divide over guns
is so stark the governor of texas and
his ally in the senate the men who block
all attempts to change gun laws they are
here and not unwelcome there are 19 sets
of parents
who who are never going to get to kiss
their child tonight
again
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important it's at the
heart of the issue i i get that that's
where the media likes to go it's not
it's where many of the people we've
talked to here like to go the proposals
from democrats in the media
inevitably when some violent
psychopath murders people a violent
psychopath who's able to get a weapon so
easily 18 year old with two ar-15s if
you want to stop
violent crime
the proposals the democrats have none of
them would have stopped this why does
this only happen in your country i
really think that's what many people
around the world just
they cannot fathom why only in america
why is this american exceptionalism so
awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect of it
you get your political agenda no it's us
god love you senator it's not i just
want to understand why you do not think
that guns are the problem why is this
just an american problem
it is just an american problem sir mr
cruz why is america the only country
that faces this kind of you know what
mass shooting but you can't answer that
you can't answer that can you say you
can't answer that why is this why why is
it that people come from all over the
world to america because it's the freest
most prosperous safest country maybe
it may be the freestyle maybe the most
part
if that wasn't clear enough the
governor's earlier news conference
struck the heart of this gulf in
american society
this isn't the place to talk to you this
is totally predictable
you're out of line
the republican leader of this state
clashing with his democratic rival no
common ground no compromise
and so they left the vigil in their town
that will now be remembered for just one
thing until the next one
mark stone sky news in texas